a carpet measures seven feet long and
has a diagonal measurement of square
root of 74 feet find the width of the
carpet so let's draw ourselves a carpet
here
so let's draw a carpet
it has a length of seven feet so let's
say that that is seven feet right there
and it's going to be a rectangle of some
kind so let's say that this is we're
looking down on the carpet like that
that's our carpet and then it has a
diagonal measurement of square root of
74 feet a diagonal measurement so that
means that this distance right here we
draw a little bit neater than that
this distance right here the diagonal of
the carpet is the square root of 74 feet
and what they want to know is the width
of the carpet find the width of the
carpet so let's say that this is the
width of the carpet carpet that is w
right there
now you might already realize that what
i've drawn here is a right triangle let
me make sure you realize it this is a 90
degree angle here and since that is a
triangle that has a 90 degree angle it's
a right triangle the side opposite the
the right angle or the 90 degrees is the
hypotenuse or the longest side it is the
square root of 74 and the shorter sides
are w and seven and the pythagorean
theorem tells us that the sum of the
squares of the shorter side will be
equal to the square of the hypotenuse so
the square of the longest side so we get
w squared this side squared
plus 7 squared
plus 7 squared this other side squared
is going to be equal to the hypotenuse
squared square root of 74
squared and then we get
w squared plus
is equal to the square root of 74
squared well that's just going to be 74
is equal to 74. we can subtract 49 from
both sides of this equation so we have
just a w squared on the left hand side
subtract 49
from both sides the left side these guys
are going to cancel out we're just going
to be left with a w squared is equal to
what's 74 minus 49 74 minus 49 well we
could do a little bit of regrouping or
borrowing here if we don't want to do it
in our head to make this a 14 this
becomes a six 14 minus nine is five
six minus four is two
and we have w squared is equal to 25 so
w is going to be equal to the square
root of 25 the positive square root
so let's take the square root of both
sides the positive square root and we
will get w
is equal to
five because we want obviously we don't
want it to be negative five that
wouldn't be a realistic distance so the
width of the carpet is five and we're
done